there was some news today uh the Biden
stuff and I'm just like I don't I don't
care man look we get it the bidens are
crooked they're dirty people and I
started thinking about this jackpot I
did a segment of 4pm jeffysovic wrote
about his old neighborhood when he was a
kid and how it's falling apart and crime
ridden and then I'm just like yeah
that's the result it it's they're
actually all symptoms of the same thing
cultural fragmentation I was saying that
you know you go back imagine a small
town of 3000 people and you've got a
nice God-fearing white family a nice
God-fearing black family a nice
God-fearing Latino family my point is
they uh Asian family they they agree
culturally and ideologically on their
world view race doesn't matter their
views on morality are all the same so if
one guy loses his job and goes on
unemployment nobody's mad about it
they're like we got your back buddy you
know don't worry we'll see you at church
on Sunday and he's like I'm gonna keep
trying I know you guys are there for me
and then eventually finds a a job no one
is you know when when everybody agrees
with each other and wants me be part of
the same Community they're not looking
to exploit each other they're not
looking to commit crimes against each
other they got each other's back social
programs work crime is low you don't
need police and then I started thinking
about what what the Biden family
represents and it's just like
they're they're both a symptom of and
the cause of it's it's like it's like a
Whirlpool you get when you have a
fractured moral society and people just
stop caring and you get Democrats who
are like I'm voting for this guy simply
because I hate you then the people they
end up voting for like the bidens are
crime families
and then because you end up with a crime
family in government they end up burning
everything to the ground he's kind of
like a that's not quite an old wash-up
politician he's kind of like an old
washed up politician like after 1988
when he was plagiarizing in his
presidential run he had to drop out of
the race he was pretty much laughed at
scorned and like never taken seriously
again until all of a sudden Obama
puts him as his VP he runs he looks like
a daughtering old man in 19 in 2008 no
one took him seriously with his run
against Obama and then all of a sudden I
guess now we find out it was the
establishment that it's the DNC it's
like the Democratic party that selects
the running mate I thought Obama put him
in as like oh I want an old white guy I
want like a business guy to like
represent that business part because I'm
the rebel no man you remember they ran
it by him and then Biden was and then
Biden had that Infamous little script
where he was like you know we had to
First clean well-spoken black guy and
you know it was like a fairy you know
they literally had the place set up and
so it's just it's it's kind of funny
because you know Tim you were saying
it's just like all of all the people
hate each other and they vote candidates
in just despite other people well then
that means Biden is literally just like
an embodiment of the hatred and contempt
that Americans have for each other yeah
you see that in how they govern they
have hatred and contempt for us you know
and the way they conduct themselves
right like I have never found a reason
to write about it but like Hunter Biden
has this illegitimate child who he won't
acknowledge even though he puts her mom
on the payroll for a while and like now
her mom who I believe was a stripper I'm
not sure
um is like trying to get her daughter to
have the Biden last name so that she is
you know acknowledged she's connected
because it's beneficial to be to be
known in America as a Biden and to me
like this is someone who doesn't
acknowledge this child like it sounds
horrible to to saddle your child with
the name of a man who doesn't want to
acknowledge her who had another child
after who they bring out for photos like
it's he's resisting he's trying to stop
this he has asked the judge to Pro to uh
to not let this happen meanwhile Grandma
Joe Biden like brings his toddler son
that he had in wedlock with this South
African film director like they present
themselves to this family and they love
the young women and they're so
supportive and then really on the other
hand like they don't they don't practice
anything they preach and we say this
time and time again right like no one is
perfect but it's different to say oh
this is the package we're selling you
America and please ignore the other
stuff right like it's it's just corrupt
morally it's like someone took like all
the negative things of like it's like
somebody had done does not understand
American culture except for the bad
things basically took and distilled all
of the worst aspects drugs fatherless
children money laundering corruption and
just like literally just embedded them
into Biden family at that point and
that's like literally what we have so
but Vogue did a cover of Naomi Biden's
wedding so we should just accept that
they are like the beautiful new
Americana family like it it makes me sad
right like these like Tiffany Trump and
I'm gonna make this point because I've
been thinking about it for weeks and
have not had a chance to do it to make
it but Tiffany Trump got married the
weekend before Naomi Biden right very
similar Styles very lavish wedding both
like from powerful families but like
Naomi Biden's is good and it's
representational even though her family
actually has all this Scandal and all
this weird connection and they treat
each other each other strangely and the
Trump family for by all accounts like is
unusual right a man who's been divorced
three times has all these kids like not
super typical but by all accounts all of
the siblings get along really well but
they're the bad family they're
representational of negative family
politics like it doesn't really make
sense this is this is why I did the
segment I did at 4 P.M on my on my main
Channel normally you know because
normally what I do every day is I grab
like the big story and I'm like here's
the thing that happened here's what it
means here's what's going on here's some
other stuff about it and like the other
day I was talking about oh Biden scandal
the emails apparently Hunter Biden
emails from his laptop suggests he had
access to classified information and it
seems like in emails they were directly
getting information straight from the
White House so that's a big Scandal
today there was more information on it
that they had raided the pen Biden
Center or whatever and so there's like
the FBI were doing raids on the bidens
for a while now before the midterms and
they weren't telling us and then I was
just like thinking about uh Chuck Todd
Jim Jordan goes on uh goes on Meet the
Press and he says you know Chuck Todd's
like but Trump had classified documents
and he's like Trump is the president and
they were guarded by the Secret Service
and they were locked up and Biden had
him sitting in his garage and then just
for tribal reasons Chuck Todd says no no
like you can't see it you know it's a
it's a conspiracy and it's just like we
we get it those of us of sound mind
Chuck Todd is just saying whatever he
has to because there is a cult of people
who don't care what's true they care
that they are right so you can come out
and make your argument and they don't
care literally don't care and I'm just
thinking about all this and I'm like
then I saw Jack besobic's article about
how his neighborhood fell apart and I'm
like yeah it's because we have no
cultural cohesion we have no uh shared
moral framework and so we end up with
leaders who are basically on the Titanic
watching the iceberg coming
right before it hits they run grab a
whole bunch of silverware and jump in a
Lifeboat and just cast off and instead
of actually steering the ship saving
people or being like a real Captain and
saying you know last person off the ship
or you go down with it they're off the
ship first and they don't even tell you
what happened oh no worse they're
telling you everything's fine don't
worry guys go go back to the mini bar
get some more drinks go go gamble just
get off the deck most sweet peace little
Iceberg the ship starts yeah that's
right the ship starts sinking starts
going up and people are sliding don't
worry this is the slide function it's
fun glasses are flying people are
hanging from the side and like
everything's still fine the ground is
flat I know don't question meanwhile
there are there there's a second ship
that pulled up uh funded by the Chinese
Communist party and they're they're
rowing over being like don't worry about
it Hunter get the boat
that's exactly what they're doing I
think that's I think a lot of the
business dealings Hunter Biden is doing
is basically
like these people are running this
country into the ground in more ways
than one from from neighborhoods falling
apart to the tribalistic nature of
humans uh of of of society right now I'm
wondering if their attitude is just like
look one man's not going to fix this
grab what you can every man for himself
I've been thinking about oh we're gonna
say no it's about to say it's like a
multi-layered hedge basically you know
you already know it's gonna burn down so
why not extract all the wealth that you
can that way when it burns down you're
you know sitting kind of pretty looking
like royalty then you can come back and
the ashes are there and you can suddenly
say hey guys we have money we can fix
this and then you basically take all the
credit rebuild it everybody's ground
down and depressed it's kind of like you
know Russia post-soviet collapse really
where you know that's that's why all the
drinking rusky you know sort of uh you
know those stereotypes come from because
when the Soviet collapsed they basically
gave Russian people all these waivers
and you know things like this when these
people couldn't even feed themselves and
so then basically you had the oligarchs
and the American Banks basically come
over and buy buy up all almost all the
industry and you know turn Russians into
basically slave slave workers and then
next thing you know well it's back but
now the oligarchs run everything and
they've already got all the money yeah I
got an idea
if it's all going to come crashing down
go buy some chickens
man because uh
the people who are able to sustain
themselves more than others are going to
be better off if this is the trend that
continues I do think there's an
alternative and that's why I said we
need to make America great again and I
don't know if I'm saying the exact same
way that all the Trump supporters saying
about but but I imagine probably when
Jack was up at brings up Pizza Hut when
he was a kid and there's a salad bar and
if you read a book in school they gave
you a free donut and you got a free I
don't know there's a bunch all I
remember was something that's all I
remember because I remember I get there
was a Pizza next to a Dunkin Donuts so
I'd get the free pizza and then we were
leaving and go get a free donut there
was other stuff on it like something it
was like drug addiction like they give
you the cheese and the high fructose
corn syrup and the sauce with the sugar
in your Donuts
bro I doubt back then they had all that
stuff it was like after 92 it was when
the high fructose started coming in but
we were living in a haze of ignorance at
that time you know what though maybe the
decline of literacy levels because I
know you guys see in the schools how
like kids can't even read anymore
it started when they took away the
personal pan pieces that's when it
happened
now you see how they're tweeting
God it gives me a headache bro it's just
just all the it's all like a court
stenographer shorthand and yeah yeah and
I grew and honestly I grew up with it
like you know I don't know if you guys
know this but I'm black and so you know
obviously we have our own kind of like
you know our own dialect in our own
vernacular and stuff I assumed you're a
white supremacist dude I know I know did
you see those five guys though Jesus
Christ black people anymore man these
white people out here crazy but no bro
like white supremacists man yeah Dave
spell called it what were you saying no
no no so you're black please continue I
know I know I know I hierarchy guys
hierarchy but uh but no it's it's just
sort of funny you know when you sort of
think about it you know I grew up in
where like we used our own vernacular in
our own dialect when we talked and it
was mainly just because you know it was
shorthand certain words we just didn't
know how to pronounce now now you see
people out here purposely typing like
purposely misspelling and like the
errors and just the misuse of there and
it gives me palpitations oh it's hard
for me man like where are all the
semicolons you know they exist for a
reason it's two different subjects in
one sentence there's no comma use the
semicolon to delineate the two subjects
I'm going to write you a note and I'm
Gonna Leave You in your room it's going
to have no semicolons and improper
punctuation I'm gonna puke on myself hey
I wanna I wanna tag on what you're
saying about the oligarchs earlier
because this has been crossing my mind
last night I'm like okay this Russian
invasion of Ukraine it's not Putin I
mean Putin's one of them it's the out
the Russian oligarchs that are in charge
it's it's basically a hyper capitalist
state of oligarchs are running that
thing and it's no wonder they want to
conquer a trade port in Sebastopol they
want that trade because it's what hyper
capitalists would do in Civilization if
you were playing against them and they
had a government run by a bunch of uber
people just like capitalists so but I'm
wondering
for the capitalists of the United States
the oligarchs the United States if they
want to control the world they would
want to Ally with the capitalists of
Russia against I would think either they
they're too stupid and they think that
really they can beat them
um in a sort of attrition or it's uh
they're intentionally taking us to war
to kill off the common man so that like
you said earlier they could come back
and rebuild with all their finances
that's where you're wrong kiddo because
these aren't regular capitalists these
are crony capitalists right crony
capitalists don't care about free
marketing competition they just want to
fix the game for them to win but you
know it's funny you bring that up
because actually you know Russian now
the oligarch problem isn't near as bad
as it used to be like I don't know if
you guys know this but when the IMF came
in and they tried to do what was called
shock therapy where you convert a
formerly communist Nation to a
capitalist Nation the oligarchs botched
the whole thing on purpose because they
want to buy all the infrastructure up
for cheap Putin when he came to power
actually drove most of those oligarchs
out of Russia and guess where they went
Ukraine Ukraine and to the US so a lot
of this anti-pudent sentiment that we
see you know Putin's listen let's go for
what he is I mean I'm not saying he's a
good guy but you know compared to some
of the other Russian leaders the people
of the Russian Federation he's actually
a moderate you know I've heard that uh
and you know you can't take my word for
the gospel but a lot of Russians are you
know pretty frustrated that he pity
patted you know with the war that he had
this kind of kids glove approach with
Ukraine to begin with and then you know
when they uh brought in shirovician or
general Armageddon basically now they're
going full scale anyways and they're
just like why didn't you do that you
know before and it's you know it's kind
of crazy how we have all this anti-you
know Russian rhetoric going anyways but
it's just
hold all the Darks of the past and you
know angry Rich Boomers with a uh you
know War grads against Russia just want
to finish picking the bones clean
because you know they have all that gas
you know all that cold war brainwash
yeah yeah man it's uh coming to roost so
it's crazy I'm looking at some of the
oligarchs on I just went to Wikipedia
Russian auger so we have Arcadia
ruttenberg Kennedy Tim uh timchenko
Alisha usmanov are these names ringing
about Peter Aven Mikhail Pro Corolla
Oleg deripaska there's nine of them
Alec elek perov Vladimir potanin
and Roman Abramovich he's probably the
most famous name-wise Roman Abramovich
I've heard what's what's crazy is the uh
cost of property in Ukraine because
there's no way the average Ukrainian can
own property
unless you're a coder
so I you know I know people I mentioned
my friends who are Ukrainian and they'll
say that like the average salary is like
400 bucks a month or something like that
and if you want to buy property the
prices are comparable to a property in
the United States it's like 300 000 to
buy a studio apartment in the city or
something like that and if you're making
400 bucks a month you will never buy
that but if you're a developer or coder
you're making 150k per year U.S while
living in Ukraine you're living like a
king you're over there so what ends up
happening is the way they describe it to
me the property is all owned by
oligarchs and everyone else has to rent
from them and they you can buy it it's
for sale but only the wealthiest people
and foreigners come and actually buy up
the property ukrainians struggle with it
so they own nothing but do they like it
you know it's a pretty chill place they
got cabbage and uh you can get cabbage
and beef and stuff like that I I when I
was in Kiev I was at the mydan square it
it was awesome it was a blast it was it
was it's a cool place so it really sucks
what's been what's been going on to be
completely honest going to little food
buffets they had I remember when I was
there
we were they had like a music the TV
playing with music music on it and then
uh Paris Hilton came on music video and
then I was like you guys get Paris
Hilton here my friend was like of course
we get all the American celebrities and
I'm like no no no no no you don't
understand Paris Hilton music doesn't
exist in the United States like we don't
listen to it and you guys do and that's
kind of funny to me I don't know I was
thinking about this Invasion and where
there's a lot of like Kickback now from
my friends that I guess you consider
more liberal they're like Ukraine is
Ukraine we're not we don't want Ukraine
to give up anything Russians should not
be invading get out we will will send
American troops to die to keep up and
I'm like where was your voice when the
United States invaded Iraq we're still
invading Iraq The Invasion doesn't stop
the day after it starts if we're still
at Presence there we've we're invading
in the moment where's your why aren't
you speaking out against what you can
actually control
a lot of them are too young a lot of
them are too young and just
if I can be crass too stupid to even
understand that you know people don't
see the whole bigger picture honestly
you know Ian mentioned we were living in
ignorance and someone super chatted
saying uh this is a Christopher Marr
saying in living in Haze of ignorance is
called living the dream but I think what
ends up happening is
you get a generation that raises their
kids in ignorance
then when they pass on the World to
those kids that's what you get
you get the bidens you get people being
like vosh when he came on the show and
I'm like what isn't isn't the corruption
of the Biden family from when he was VP
like a concern to you and he's like oh I
don't know anything about it I was a
little kid I was in high school when
that happened I didn't pay attention and
I'm like oh so like the bad guy
runs for office 10 years later and
you're just like I just heard of this
guy you know you're like uh-huh there's
a lot of bad guys you gotta look into
who they are yeah I think that's what
you know I can't say the rnt isn't
guilty of this but definitely DNC like
that's why they like young voters
because it's like a a blank slate yeah
yeah I would say the DNC like that's why
they often push these guys but I think
the RNC too I think all political
parties operate this way but I think any
time you get this new class of 18 year
olds who have the right to vote they
don't remember 30 years of political
history and especially it's even ones
who are super politically engaged they
just haven't had enough time to learn
everything and all the nuances and why
this Senator doesn't get along with that
one and this deal you know you can only
know so much when you're young but
getting them getting anyone to support
your ideology especially when you buy in
with like sort of the name brand I think
I think of a lot of modern politics like
rooting for sports teams you know like
you don't know why your family supports
this team you just do uh I I think that
is something that some political parties
take in stride you know they don't have
to explain the sins of people they're
now electing to president things that
they did when they were Senators mean
nothing to people who are new voters
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time